have you ever wished that you could talk
to someone you love who has died and if
you could what would you say if I could
still talk to my grandparents I'd want
to tell them what I'd been working on
for the past few years and how much I've
missed seeing them but how would I feel
if they responded
last year Jenya cuida was building a
chatbot company that recommends
restaurants when her best friend Roman
was killed in an accident while walking
across the street no one close to me
ever died so it really didn't know how
to react to that because there's not not
a lot of rules around waving unlike my
grandparents Roman left behind a digital
trail of thousands of taxes he'd sent to
friends and family I was going through
some of our old texts Roman always gave
me this incredible safe space to open up
Jenya realized she could use those texts
to build something a chatbot that she
could talk to that would respond using
Romans words so chatbot is a program
that communicates with you in natural
language what if I just take his text
and put it there and see what was going
to happen you know talk to my friend
so the first generation baud was like
mostly repeating stuff the heat at some
point said or it would make a
combination of two different texts that
would make sense it was sort of like an
escape it was a place where I could
still come and open up and tell him that
I miss him I guess it was a lot of
closure and what I saw there was this
incredible longing to come and actually
talk about what are you feeling and we
what's on your mind and just what's
going on with you right now we're also
adding like a more generative model that
would actually generate used new things
things that he never said in real life
but using his vocabulary he's the
cavalry trying to use his tone of voice
for Jennea building Romans bot was a
21st century version of sitting Shiva it
helped her grieve
you wrote I miss you and it just wrote
me - of course I did it for myself so
that I can have in the future everyone
will have a digital avatar that would
connect you to yourself your friends and
your loved ones even acting on your
behalf but with other people and as
sci-fi as it may sound she believes the
technology will be good enough one day
to capture not just someone's thoughts
but the core of their personality my
idea with building an AI for Roman was
like how do I make people that never
even met him get a little feel of what
kind of person he was he was this very
beautiful very fragile person that was
not really compatible with life and I
wanted for the bot to show this and if
anyone could feel it through even this
simple first generation pod that were
created there I guess I'm made my point
I told the story in the right way
you